so we talked a little bit about the
soviet union and
i happen to have lived through the
collapse of the soviet union
and so what are the factors that causes
in your mind to why the soviet union
collapsed
so i you know definitely a multivariate
situation i think there's a lot of
factors
um one that jumped out to me recently
again from that documentary that i
didn't note before was that at one point
stalin eliminated i think 75 of his
intelligence
force um
which i think when you're competing with
another nation state
you know and intelligence and covert
operations are very integral
to your survival i think that was a
definitely a shot in the foot but
at a higher level i would say that
capitalism and communism were each
resource
strategies of the 20th century
nation-state
and they seemed you know we commonly
consider them to be diametrically
opposed but there's actually a lot of
commonality between the two the
difference would be that
in soviet russia as we alluded to
earlier
they tried to completely replace price
signals with this
nationalistic faith and devotion so it
it they removed
the economic nerve signal which
coordinated the allocation of capital
over time
so this inhibited their ability to
generate wealth
whereas in the united states we left
most markets
open to free enterprise so we we
honored the integrity of price signals
and we allowed
people to trade and accumulate wealth um
so in every market except the market for
money both markets
maintained a central bank as we as we've
gotten to so
i think in a really big picture
standpoint
that's why capitalism out competes
communism is because it is
able to generate more wealth than
communism was
and therefore was able to put financial
pressure on
the ussr until it reached the point of
bankruptcy
essentially this a similar
model i would argue is it
for the same reasons we saw capitalism
outcompete communism which i think at
the the data that i recall was that the
ussr's economy was valued at close to
one-third of its inputs
so if you just didn't do anything inside
the ussr and just sold all the raw
materials that were going into it
it would have been worth three times as
much as
sending the materials in running it
through the efforts and then shipping
things back out it was it was
value destructive versus value creative
and i would argue this is because again
the
centralized computing model versus
decentralized computing model
it just became more and more corrupt
over time
um it got to the point where i think
most
of the occupations in ussr towards the
end were as informants
right they were working for the state
jordan peterson makes this point too
that at some point it was actually
illegal to be sad
in soviet russia because if you were sad
you were contradicting the utopian view
of the state
so if you were sad you're implying the
state's not doing something wrong
you